non mais c'est comme si moi j'accuse à
Balkany détourner de l'argent et qui
m'attaquait pour diffamation
et maintenant voici mon stagiaire Tom
villa
[Applaudissements]
waouh c'est bien entré sur du verdict
comme ça
grand compositeur verdict d'ailleurs
vous l'avez dit Roselyne Verdi vous
prend par les couilles voilà j'ai dit ça
contrairement à la musique de Carla
Bruni qui elle nous les casses
alors pas de débrief cette semaine
Thierry par contre voilà juste une
petite mise au point on est d'accord
c'est vous qui avez lancé le magazine
Entrevue il y a 20 ans que là vous avez
face à vous un grand patron de presse
qui sort un nouveau magazine ça
s'appelle Rebel santé voilà ça c'est le
journal de Thierry Ardisson
[Applaudissements]
mais si c'est vous Thierry je sais pas
moi du tout des fois je vous jure on
s'emmerde à chercher des vannes là et
ton tout seul comme ça
la rédac voilà rebelle santé alors voilà
pour tous ceux qui prennent des
médicaments mais qui sont battent les
couilles des dosages voilà exactement
[Applaudissements]
là ce soir il y en a pour tout le monde
capillairement c'est c'est au top blond
brun brushing bouclette ce soir c'est
plus une émission c'est une pub L'Oréal
c'est vrai
Roselyne Bachelot bonsoir Roselyne
bonsoir bon Roselyne je l'adore elle a
quasiment réussi à nous faire oublier
qu'elle allait bossé avec Sarkozy c'est
très Florent non mais depuis que vous
faites plus de politique Rosine vous
êtes devenu comme ce qu'on appelle une
bonne cliente voilà vous êtes capable de
déclamer un superbe poème et une blague
de cul derrière en fait Roselyne c'est
le Chenon manquant entre Luchini
Jean-Marie Bigard
donc c'est vrai
mais ce que j'aime par dessus tout est
grosse lignes c'est que elle a peur de
rien qui t'as su faire des ennemis
Rosine vous êtes en procès avec Raphaël
Nadal que vous avez accusé dopage dalle
il a tellement mal pris qui et qui vous
a attaqué c'est pas comme si on s'en
doutait pas enfin il a un bras un bras
gauche et la cuisse d'une vache non mais
tu regardes son biceps il y a écrit EPO
avec ses veines donc quand même c'est
bah voilà non mais c'est comme si moi
j'accusais Balkany détourner de l'argent
et qui m'attaquait pour diffamation
max Boublil bonsoir
Julian Perretta il s'appelle giulian il
nous vient de loin s'il avait le monde
entier à ses trous on aurait eu Julian
Assange heureusement il n'a que des
gamines de 15 ans qu'il poursuivent dans
la rue cette Julian Perretta mesdames
[Applaudissements]
es en 2009 vous avez chanté sur la
tournée Beyoncé c'est la classe en 2015
vous avez joué dans le spectacle de Kev
Adams et vous êtes ici pour nous dire
qui utilise le plus de démêlant et de
fer à lisser voilà Alexandra Lamy
bonsoir
Alexandra la classe sur TF1 avec après
moi le bonheur vous avez cartonné vous
incarné une maman atteinte d'un cancer
et vous avez accepté de jouer sans
maquillage bravo voilà quand on sait
qu'une semaine sans maquillage de
Roselyne Bachelot c'est un phoque de
sauver
et Thierry c'est un ours blanc voilà
j'ai même pas demandé à être maquillée
bon Alexandra bon on va pas se mentir
voilà il y a des il y a des petits
sujets sensibles chez vous comme Jean
Dujardin votre sœur mais je fais tout le
monde il y a des sujets sensibles
Roselyne c'est les vaccins Julian c'est
ses cheveux non Thierry c'est son âge
les partouze les rides
[Applaudissements]
n'en parlera pas et moi le premier moi
j'ai pas envie qu'en tant que stagiaire
on sèche tout de ma vie privée voilà
vous connaissez le problème ce qui se
passe à la photocopieuse doit rester à
la photocopieuse voilà
Mesdames et Messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
Thierry Ardisson n'a pas voulu vous
poser
Julian perrettable Julian votre papa est
italien et votre maman est irlandaise du
coup ça donne quoi le tiramisu à la
Guinness c'est bon ou pas
Alexandra Lamy aujourd'hui vous vivez à
Londres si c'est ni pour les impôts ni
pour la météo quel intérêt
Roselyne Bachelot Roselyne vous avez dit
entrevoir une [__] et un cerveau que
vous avez choisi d'avoir un cerveau ça
veut dire que Nabilla a une [__]
[Applaudissements]
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu